[Music]  actor and comedian Jim Nabors has died  at the age of 87 Nabors was best known  for his TV performance as Gomer Pyle on  The Andy Griffith Show he ain't had any  luck finding a job huh no but I'm going  on the market now they're advertising  for the experience but you know anything  about cutting meat you think they'll ask  me diet the gig led to neighbors own  spin off a Gomer Pyle USMC we had such a  rat poor and fondness for each other and  it all stemmed from Andy he you know  made it all happen and so in addition to  his comedic and acting chops neighbors  stunned audiences with his striking  singing voice as he often demonstrated  on TV  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  you